Speaker 1: Donald Trump Jr. made a big splash
this weekend, tweeting that he trusts, trusts,
podcast host, comedian and May commentator
Joe Rogan more than he trusts.
Dr. Anthony Fauci, who heads up the NIH is
the top infectious disease doctor in the United
States, has spent his career working on infectious
disease.
Now, of course, this comes at no surprise
Speaker 2: that junior
Speaker 1: trusts Rogan more than Fauci.
Not shocking, but sadly, it's emblematic of
a bigger problem in the United States.
And you might say, Yeah, David, it's called
stupidity.
Yeah, I know, I know, but I to speak a little
more specifically when it comes to authority
and expertize.
There is now a particular problem in the United
States.
There is a logical fallacy called the appeal
to authority.
Appeal to authority is a fallacy where one
claims something must be true because it comes
from someone believed to be an authority on
that subject.
Now you might say, well, authorities on subjects
are more trustworthy.
That's exactly the point.
I'm going to get to that.
As I've said before, a little bit of knowledge
can be a dangerous thing.
Speaker 2: And now that these radical
Speaker 1: zealots heard about the appeal
to authority fallacy, or they might not even
know that's what it's called, but just experts
don't know everything, OK?
They are often quick to say experts, Schmidt
experts.
That's an appeal to authority fallacy.
Now, of course, there are two important details
about the appeal to authority fallacy.
First of all, it's only a fallacy if you claim
that something must be true only on the basis
of a certain person saying it that then it
is a fallacy.
It might still be true, but it is the fallacy.
Secondly, if someone is actually an authority
on the subject matter, it's not a fallacy.
Unless, again, it's the
Speaker 2: idea that only on
Speaker 1: that basis of it being believed
that someone is an expert, so given to put
it away, that makes more sense, given two
competing hypotheses about some phenomenon.
One from an actual expert, a real expert and
one from a layperson absent some specific
reason an evidentiary reason to believe the
expert is wrong.
Erring on the
Speaker 2: side of thinking
Speaker 1: the actual expert may be the one
who's right here is not a fallacy that's different
than the appeal to authority fallacy.
And this is unfortunately incredibly common
right now.
Uncovered, the actual experts are written
off by a misunderstanding of this fallacy.
Now there's another problem here.
The same ignorant people who misunderstand
this fallacy will often reverse it, and they
will end up saying This doctor has the right
view on COVID and it's a doctor, so you've
got to trust them.
And then you'll look and it'll be like Scott
Atlas, a radiologist who knows nothing about
infectious disease or it's a chiropractor,
which it's a type of doctor, but it's not
an M.D., and it's certainly not an expert
in infectious disease.
So that's one layer to this before I get to
the other layer.
It is ironic, maybe more like discussing that
the right loves to criticize when when they
know what it's called the right loves to criticize
the postmodern attitudes of some on the left
that everyone's opinion is valid.
All perspectives must be allowed and on and
on something I disagree with.
Speaker 2: But the right
Speaker 1: loves to caricature all the left
as believing that.
And here they are doing a version of it which
is saying, Well, you've got an infectious
disease doctor.
OK, well, that's one thing.
And then you've got, I don't know, podcast
host.
That's another.
It is valid for me to say I trust the comedian
more than I trust the doctor now.
Of course, Don.
Junior is allowed to say it, but when they
say there's an empirical reality and that's
what's so wrong with this perspective on the
left is postmodernist perspective of it's
all valid.
Listen.
Well, if you're going to be critical of that,
then you have to be able to look inward and
say, I'm kind of doing the same thing here
when I say, No, no, no.
We must allow Rogan's view to be just as valid
from an evidentiary standpoint as Dr. Fauci's.
Speaker 2: They will never that look,
Speaker 1: look, look within themselves.
They will never do that.
Now let's get to the second kind of a problem
here.
The same ignorant people who so we've talked
about
Speaker 2: layer one, which is.
Speaker 1: Junior says he trusts Rogan more
than Foushee, so it's like one layer the same
false
Speaker 2: authority applies
Speaker 1: to Don Junior weighing in on this.
And what I mean by that is there are people
in this country who will also trust Joe Rogan
over 4G.
Because Joe, because Don Junior said it.
OK, so this is like a second layer.
It's like concatenated expert confusion or
like Russian Dolls, you know, those matryoshka
dolls one goes inside the other of expertize
confusion.
Don Junior Miss analyzes the expertize of
Rogan versus Fauci on COVID and then others
in turn mis analyze Don Jr's expertize on
identifying who is more trustworthy on COVID.
And that's where it really gets ugly.
Speaker 2: To make an analogy,
Speaker 1: imagine I don't know.
He would never do this, but imagine Sam Setor
said.
I trust Pacman more than Rogan on me.
Well, Sam
Speaker 2: misunderstanding
Speaker 1: expertize because I don't know
a damn thing about me and Joe Rogan does.
But then trusting Sam to ascertain whether
I or Joe Rogan know more about me is that
second layer.
And that's what we're talking about.
And unfortunately, the Trump family looked
upon almost like deities by many in this country,
and they are immediately taken to the idea
that, well, if Don Jr. has assessed that Rogan
is more trustworthy than Fauci, then that's
good enough for me.
You get it.
Bottom line is, we're in real trouble.
That's essentially the takeaway here